The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Last time, which is
now two weeks ago, we started
the talk about the signals and
systems approach, by which I
mean, think about a system by
the way it transforms its
input signal into an
output signal.
That's kind of a bizarre way
of thinking about systems.
I demonstrated that last time by
thinking about a mass and a
spring, something you have a
lot of experience with, but
you probably didn't use this
kind of approach for
thinking about it.
Over this lecture and over the
next lecture, what I'd like to
do is show you the advantages
of this kind of approach.
And so for today, what I'd like
to do is talk about how
to think about feedback within
this structure, and I'd like
to also think about how you
can use this structure to
characterize the performance
of a system in a
quantitative fashion.
So first off, I want to just
think about feedback.
Feedback is so pervasive
that you don't notice
it most of the time.
You use feedback in virtually
everything that you do.
Here is a very simple example
of driving a car.
If you want to keep the car in
the center of your lane,
something that many people
outside of Boston, at least,
think is a good idea, then you
are mentally doing feedback.
You're constantly comparing
where you are to where you'd
like to be and making small
adjustments to the system
based on that.
When you think of even the most
simple of systems, like
the thermostat in a house--
I'm not talking about
a cheap motel.
The cheap motels
don't do this.
But in a real house, there's a
thermostat, which regulates
the temperature.
That's important, because if
the temperature suddenly
drops, it would never do that
of course, but if the
temperature ever dropped, it
could compensate for it.
Here's one of my favorite
examples.
Feedback is enormously
pervasive in biology.
There's no general rules in
biology, but to a first cut,
everything is regulated.
And in many cases, the
regulation is amazing.
Here's an example from 6.021,
where it's illustrating the
system that your body uses to
regulate glucose delivery from
food sources to every cell in
your body, which is crucial to
your being cognizant
and mobile.
And the idea is that it does
that with amazing precision
despite the fact that
eating and exercise
are enormously episodic.
In order for you to remain
healthy and functional, you
need to have something between
approximately two and ten
millimoles per liter
of glucose in your
blood at all times.
Were it to go higher than that,
systematically, you
would develop cardiac problems
and could lead to even
congestive heart failure.
If you were to have lower than
two millimoles per liter, you
would go comatose.
That's a very narrow range,
two to five, especially
because what we eat is so
episodic, when we exercise is
so episodic.
It's amazing, and just to
dramatize how amazing it is,
how much sugar do you
think circulates in
your blood right now?
Well, if you convert five
millimoles per liter, and if
you assume the average person
has about three liters of
blood, which is true, and if you
calculate it, that comes
out to 2.7 grams.
That's this much.
This is 2.7 grams
of table sugar.
So this is how much sugar
is in your blood, now.
This is what's keeping
you healthy.
This is what's keeping you
from becoming comatose.
Or not.
How much sugar do you
think is in this?
AUDIENCE: The amount
in that other cup.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
We call that the Theory
of Lectures.
I don't want to look like
an idiot, so my
problems make sense.
This is the amount of sugar
in a can of soda.
Numerically, this is 39 grams.
That's more than 13
times this much.
So when you down one of these,
it's very important that the
sugar gets taken out of the
blood quickly, and it does.
And that happens by way of a
feedback system, and the
feedback system is
illustrated here.
Basically, the feedback involves
the hormone insulin,
and that's why insulin
deficiency is such a
devastating disease.
Finally, everything we do
has feedback in it.
Think about how your
life would be
different if it didn't.
Even a simple task, like
removing a light bulb, would
be virtually impossible except
for the fact that you get
feedback from everything.
Your hand's amazing.
You have touch sensors, you have
proprioceptive sensors,
you have stress sensors on the
muscles and ligaments, and
they all coordinate to tell you
when to stop squeezing on
the light bulb so you
don't break it.
That's all completely amazing,
and what we'd like to do,
then, is think about that kind
of a system, a feedback
system, within the signals
and systems construct.
As an example, I want to think
through the WallFinder problem
that you did last week
in Design Lab.
I'm sure you all remember that,
in that problem, we were
trying to move the robot to a
fixed distance away from the
wall, and we thought about
that as a feedback system
comprised of three parts,
a controller, a
plant, and a sensor.
We wrote difference equations to
characterize each of those
parts, and then we figured out
how to solve those difference
equations to make some
meaningful prediction about
how the robot would work.
So just to make sure you're
all on board with me, now,
here's a question for you.
These are the equations
that describe
the WallFinder problem.
How many equations and how
many unknowns are there?
Take 20 seconds, talk to your
neighbor, figure out an answer
between (1) and (5).
Unlike during the exam next
week, you are allowed to talk.
[CLASSROOM SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
PROFESSOR: T and K are no.
PROFESSOR: OK, so what's the
answer, number (1), (2), (3),
(4), or (5)?
Everybody raise your hands.
Let me see if I got the answer.
OK.
Come on, raise your hands.
Come on, everybody vote.
If you're wrong, just blame
it on your neighbor.
You had a poor partner.
That's the idea.
Right?
So you can all vote, and you
don't need to worry about
being wrong.
And you're all wrong, so
that worked out well.
OK, so I don't like the-- so
the predominant answer is
number (2).
I don't like number (2).
Can somebody think of a reason,
now that you know the
answer by the Theory
of Lectures, the
answer is not (2)?
Why isn't the answer (2)?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Oh, I was
saying (5).
PROFESSOR: You were
Why did you say (5)?
AUDIENCE: I don't remember for
sure, but can you substitute n
for different things?
Like Df of n, you could
substitute n for, and if you
did that you would have two
equations, which is
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
kind of thing, you count
before or after doing
substitution and
simplification.
And I mean to count before
you do simplification.
Any other issues?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is D0 [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Say again?
AUDIENCE: D0 [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Is D0_n different
or the same from D0_n-1?
That's the key question.
So I want to think about this
as a system of algebraic
equations, and if I do that,
then there's a lot of them.
So it looks like there's
three equations.
The problem with that approach
is that there's actually three
equations for every
value of n.
If you think about a system of
equations that you could solve
with an algebra solver, you
would have to treat all the
n's separately.
That's what we call the
samples approach.
So here's a way you
could solve them.
You could think about what if
k and t are parameters, so
they're known, they're given?
What if my input signal is
known, say it's a unit sample
signal, for example?
What would I need to
solve this system?
Well, I'd need to tell you
the initial conditions.
So in some sense, I want to
consider those to be known.
So my knowns kind of comprise
t and k, the initial
conditions for the output of the
robot, and the sensor, all
of the input signals because I'm
telling you the input and
asking you to calculate
the output.
My unknowns are all of the
different velocities for all
values of n bigger than or equal
to 0 because I didn't
tell you those.
All of the values of robot's
output at samples
n bigger than 0.
All the values of the sensor
output for values
n bigger than 0.
So I get a lot of unknowns,
infinitely many, and I get a
lot of equations, also
infinitely many.
So the thing I want you think
about is, if you're thinking
about solving difference
equations using algebra,
that's a big system
of equations.
By contrast, what if you were
to try to solve the system
using operators?
Now, how many equations and
unknowns do you see?
By the Theory of Lectures.
OK, raise your hand.
Or talk to your neighbor so you
can blame your neighbor.
Talk to your neighbor.
Get a good alibi.
[CLASSROOM SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
PROFESSOR: So the idea here
is that if you think about
operators instead, so that you
look at a whole signal at a
time, then each equation only
specifies one relationship
among signals, and there's a
small number of signals.
So if I think about the knowns
being k, t the parameters and
the signal d(i), and if I think
about the unknowns being
the velocity, the output, and
the sensor signal, then I get
three equations and
three unknowns.
So one of the values of thinking
about the operator
approach is that it just simply
reduces the amount of
things you need to
think about.
It reduces complexity.
That's what we're trying
to do in this course.
We're trying to think of methods
that allow you to
solve problems by reducing
complexity.
We would like, ultimately,
to solve very complicated
problems, and this operator
approach is an approach that
lets you do that.
It does a lot more
than that, too.
It also generates new
kinds of insights.
So it lets you focus on the
relations, but the relation is
now not quite the same
as we would have
expected from algebra.
Now, the relation between the
input signal and the output
signal is an operator.
We're going to represent the
operation that transforms the
input to the output
by this symbol, h.
We'll call that the
system functional.
It's an operator.
It's a thing that, when operated
on x, gives you y.
And this is one of the main
purposes of today's lecture,
it's also convenient to think
about h as a ratio.
We like to think of it that
way because, as we'll see,
there's a way of thinking
about h as a ratio of
polynomials in R. So two ways
of thinking about it.
We're trying to develop a
signals and systems approach
for thinking about feedback.
We want to think about the
input goes into a box.
The box represents
an operation.
We will characterize that
by a functional.
We'll call the functional h.
The functional, when applied
to the input, produces the
output, and what we'd like to do
is infer what is the nature
of that functional, and what
are the properties of the
system that functional
represents.
OK, so I see that you're
all with me.
Think about the WallFinder
system.
Think about the equations for
the various components of that
system when expressed
an operator form.
And figure out the system
functional for that system.
figure out the ratio of
polynomials that can be in r
that is represented by h.
Take 30 seconds, talk to your
neighbor, figure out whether
the answer is (1), (2),
(3), (4), or (5).
So what's the answer -- (1),
(2), (3), (4), or (5)?
Come on, more voter
participation.
All right?
Blame it on your partner.
OK, virtually 100% correct.
So the idea is algebra.
You solve the operator equations
exactly as though
they were algebraic.
Here, I've started with the
second equation and just done
substitutions until I got
rid of everything other
than d(0) and d(i).
So I express v in terms of ke,
then I express e in terms of
d(i) minus rd(0).
Then I'm left with one equation
that relates d(0) and
d(i), which I can solve
for the ratio.
And the answer comes out there,
which was number (3).
Point is that you can treat the
operator just as though it
were algebra, so that results
in enormous implications.
But what we want to understand
is what's the relationship
between that functional, that
thing that we just calculated,
and the behaviors.
These are the kinds of behaviors
that you observed
with the WallFinder system.
When you built the WallFinder
system, depending on what you
made k, you could get behaviors
that were monotonic
and slow, faster and
oscillatory, or even faster
and even more oscillatory.
And what we'd like to know is,
before we build it, how should
we have constructed the
system so that it
has a desirable behavior?
And, incidentally, are these
the best you can do?
Or is there some other set of
parameters that's lurking
behind some door that we just
don't know about, and if we
could discover it, it would
work a lot better?
So the question is, given the
structure of our problem,
what's the most general kind of
answer that we can expect?
And how do we choose the best
behavior out of that set of
possible behaviors?
So that's what I want to think
about for the rest of the hour
and a half, and I want to
begin by taking a step
backwards and look at
something simpler.
The idea's going to be the same
as the idea that we used
when we studied Python.
I want to find simple behaviors,
think about that as
a primitive, and combine
primitives to get a more
complicated behavior, so I want
to use an approach that's
very much PCAP.
Find the most simple behavior,
and then see if I can leverage
that simple behavior to somehow
understand more
complicated things.
So let's think about this very
simple system that has a
feedback loop that has a delay
in it and a gain of P0.
What I want to do is think
about what would be the
response of that very simple
system if the input were a
unit sample.
So find y, given that the
input x is delta.
In order to do that, I have to
start the system somehow.
I will start it at rest.
You've all seen already, I'm
sure, that rest is the
simplest assumption
I can make.
I'll say something at the end of
the hour about how you deal
with things that are
not at rest.
For the time being, we'll
just assume rest
because that's simple.
Assume that the system is at
rest, that means that the
output of every delay
box is 0.
That's what rest means.
If the output of this starts at
0, then the output of the
scale by P0 is also 0.
And if that's 0, and if the
input is at 0 because I'm at
time before 0, then the output
is 0, indicated here.
So now if I step, then the
input becomes 1 because
delta of 0 is 1.
The output of the delay box is
still 0, so the first answer
is 1, the 1 just propagates
straight through
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] box.
Then I step, and the 1 that was
here goes through the r
and becomes 1, the 1 goes
through P0 and becomes P0, but
at the same time, the 1 that
was at the input goes to 0
because the input is 1 only
at time equals 0.
So the result, then, is that
after one step, the
output has become P0.
This propagated to 1, that
became P0, add it to 0, and it
became P0, so now the answer,
which had been 1, is P0.
On the next step, a very
similar thing happens.
The P0 that was here becomes the
output of the delay, gets
multiplied by P0 to give you P0
squared, gets added to 0 to
give you P0 squared,
et cetera.
The thing that I want you to see
is that the output was in
some sense simple.
The value simply increased as
P0 to the n, geometrically.
There's another way we
can think about that.
I just did the sample by sample
approach, but the whole
theme of this part
of the course
is the signals approach.
If I think about the whole
signal in one fell swoop, then
I can develop an operator
expression to
characterize the system.
The operator expression says the
signal y is constructed by
adding the signal x to
the signal P0RY.
If I solve that for the ratio of
the output to input, I get
1 over (1 minus P0R).
Again, going back to the idea
that I started with, that
we're going to get ratios of
polynomials in R now the R is
in the bottom, and now I can
expand that just as though it
were an algebraic expression.
I can expand 1 over P0R in
a power series by using
synthetic division.
The result is very similar in
structure to the result we saw
in sample by sample.
It consists of an ascending
series in R, which means an
ascending number of delays.
Every time you increase the
number of delays by 1, you
also multiply the amplitude by
P0, so this is, in fact, the
same kind of result,
but viewed from a
signal point of view.
Finally, I want to think about
it in terms of block diagrams.
Same idea, I've got the same
feedback system, but now I
want to take advantage of this
ascending series expansion
that I did and think about
each of the terms in that
series as a signal flow path
through the feedback system.
So one, the first term in the
ascending series, represents
the path that goes directly from
the input to the output,
passing through no delays.
The second term in the series,
P0R, represents the path that
goes to the output, loops
around, comes back through the
adder, and then comes out.
In traversing that more
complicated path, you picked
up 1 delay and 1
multiply by P0.
Second term, two loops.
Third term, three loops.
Fourth term, four loops.
The idea is that the block
diagram gives us a way to
visualize how the answer
came about.
It came about by all the
possible paths that lead from
the input to the output.
Those possible paths all
differed by a delay, and
that's why the decomposition
was so simple, each path
corresponding to a different
number of
delays through the system.
That won't always be true from
more complicated systems, but
it is true for this one.
This flow diagram also lets
you see something that's
extremely interesting.
Cyclical flow paths, which are
characteristic of feedback--
feedback means the signal
comes back.
Cyclical flow paths require that
transient inputs generate
persistent outputs.
They generate persistent outputs
because the output at
time n is not triggered by
the input at time n.
It's triggered by the output
at time n minus 1.
It keeps going on itself.
That's fundamental
to feedback.
There's no way of getting
around that.
That's what feedback is.
And it also shows why you got
that funny oscillatory
behavior in WallFinder.
There wasn't any way
around that.
Feedback meant that you
were looping back.
That meant that there
was a cycle in
the signal flow paths.
That means that even transient
signals, signals that go away
very quickly like the
[INAUDIBLE] sample, generate
responses that go on forever.
So that's a fundamental way
of thinking about systems.
Systems are either feedforward
or feedback.
Feedforward means that
there are no cyclic
paths in the system.
No path in the system that take
you from the input to the
output has a cycle in it.
That's what acyclic means.
That's what feedforward means.
Acyclic, feedforward, those
all have responses to
transient inputs that
are transient.
That contrasts with
cyclic systems.
A cyclic system has feedback
and will have the property
that transient signals
can generate
outputs that go on forever.
OK, how many of these
systems are cyclic?
Easy questions.
15 seconds, talk to
your neighbor.
OK, so what's the answer?
How many?
OK, virtually 100%.
Correct, the answer's (3).
I've illustrated the cycles in
red, so there's a cycle here,
there's two cycles in this one,
and there's a cycle here.
So the idea is that, when you
see a block diagram, one of
the first things you want to
characterize, because it's
such a big difference between
systems, is whether or not
there's a cycle in it.
If there's a cycle, then you
know there's feedback.
If there's feedback, then you
know you have the potential to
have a persistent response to
even a transient signal.
OK, so if you only have one
loop of the type that I
started with, where we had just
one loop with an R and a
P0, then the question is, as you
go around the loop, do the
samples get bigger,
or smaller, or do
they stay the same?
That's a fundamental
characterization of how the
simple feedback system works.
So here, if on every cycle the
amplitude of the signal
diminishes by multiplication by
half, that means that the
response ultimately decays.
Mathematically, it goes on
forever, just like I said
previously, but the amplitude is
decaying, so practically it
stops after a while.
It becomes small enough that
you lose track of it.
By contrast, if every time you
go around the loop, you pick
up amplitude, if the amplitude
here were multiplied by 1.2,
then it gets bigger.
So the idea, then, is that you
can characterize this kind of
a feedback by one number.
We call that number the pole.
Very mysterious word.
I won't go into the origins
of the word.
For our purposes, it just simply
means the base of the
geometric sequence that
characterizes the response of
a system to the unit
sample signal.
So here, I've showed an
illustration of what can
happen if p is 1/2, p is one,
p is 1.2, which you can see
decay, persistence,
divergence.
Can you characterize
this system by P0?
And if so, what is P0?
Yes?
No?
[CLASSROOM SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, and virtually
everybody's
getting the right answer.
The right answer's (2).
So we like algebra.
We like negative numbers, so
we're allowed to think about
poles being negative.
In fact, by the end of the hour,
we'll even think about
poles having imaginary parts,
but for the time
being, this is fine.
If the pole were negative,
what that means is the
consecutive terms in the unit
sample response, the response
of the system to a unit sample
signal, the unit sample
response, the unit sample
response can
alternate in sine.
OK, so this then represents
all the possible behaviors
that you could get from
a feedback system
with a single pole.
If a feedback system has
a single pole, the only
behaviors that you can
get are represented
by these three cartoons.
So here, this z-axis contains
all possible values of P0.
If P0 is bigger than 1, then
the magnitude diverges, and
the signal grows
monotonically.
If the pole is between 0 and
1, the response is also
monotonic, but now it
converges towards 0.
If you flip the sign, the
relations are still the same,
except that you now get
sign alternation.
So if the P0 is between 0 and
minus 1, which is here, the
output still converges because
the magnitude of the pole is
less than 1.
But now the sign flips.
And if the pole is below minus
1, then you get alternation,
but you also get divergence.
The important thing is we
started with a simple system,
and we ended up with an
absolutely complete
characterization of it.
This is everything
that can happen.
That's a powerful statement.
When I can analyze a system,
even if it's simple, and find
all the possible behaviors,
I have something.
If you have a simple system with
a single pole, this is
all that can happen.
There might be offsets.
There might be delays.
The signal may not start until
the fifth sample, but the
persistent signal will either
grow without bounds, the k to
0, or do one of those two
with alternating sign.
That's the only things that can
happen, which of course,
begs the question, well, what
if the system's more
complicated.
OK, so here's a more
complicated system.
This system cannot be
represented by just one pole.
In fact, the system's
complicated enough you should
think through how you
would solve it.
You should all be very
comfortable with
this sort of thing.
So if you were to think about
what if I had a system like
so, and I want it to
be 1.6 minus 0.63.
What would be the output signal
at time 2 if the input
were a unit sample signal?
OK, as with all systems we're
going to think about, we have
to specify initial conditions.
The simplest kind of initial
conditions we could think
about would be rest.
If I thought about this system
at rest, then the initial
outputs of the R's would be 0.
That's at rest.
For times less than 0,
the input would be 0.
0 times 1.6 plus 0 times -0.63
plus 0 would give me 0.
Now, the clock ticks.
When the clock ticks,
it becomes times 0.
At times 0, the input is 1.
This 0 just propagated down to
here, but this was 0, so
nothing interesting happens
at the R's.
But now my output is 1.
Now, the clock ticks.
What happens?
When the clock ticks, this
1 propagates down here.
This 0 propagates down
here, but that was 0.
This 1 goes to 0 because the
input's only 1 at times 0.
So what's the output?
1.6.
Now, the clock ticks.
What happens?
Well, this 1 comes down here.
This 1.6 comes down here.
This 0 becomes another 0 because
the input has an
infinite stream of 0's after
the initial time.
So what's the output?
Well, it's 1.6 times 1.6 plus
1 times -0.63, so the answer
is number (3).
Yeah?
OK.
I forgot to write it
up there, so the
answer's in red down here.
1.6 squared minus 0.63.
OK?
The point is that it's slightly
more complicated to
think about than the case with a
single pole, and in fact, if
you use that logic to simply
step through all the
responses, you get a response
that doesn't look geometric.
The geometric sequences that we
looked at previously either
monotonically increased,
monotonically decreased
towards 0, or give one of
those two things and
alternated.
This does none of
those behaviors.
So the point is Freeman's
an idiot.
He spent all that time telling
us what one pole does, and now
two poles does something
completely different.
Right?
So the response is
not geometric.
The response grows
and then decays.
It never changes sign.
It does something completely
different from what we would
have expected from a
single pole system.
As you might expect from the
Theory of Lectures, that's not
the end of the story.
So the idea is to now capitalize
on this notion that
we can think about operators
as algebra.
If our expressions behaved like
I told you they did last
lecture, if they behaved as
entities upon which--
if they are isomorphic with
polynomials, as I said, then
there's a very cute thing we
can do with this system to
make it a lot simpler.
The thing we can do is factor.
If we think about the operator
expression to characterize
this system, the thing that's
different is that
there's an R squared.
But if R operators work just
like polynomials--
you can factor polynomials.
That's the factor theorem
from algebra.
And if I factor it, I get two
things that look like
first-order systems.
Well, that's good.
The factored form means that
I can think about this more
complicated system
as the cascade of
two first-order systems.
Well, that's pretty good.
In fact, it doesn't even matter
what order I put them
in because, as we've seen
previously, if the system
started at initial rest, then
you can swap things because
they obey all the principles of
polynomials, which include
commutation.
So what we've done, then,
is transform this more
complicated system into the
cascade of two simple systems,
and that's very good.
Even better, we can think about
the complicated system
as the sum of simpler parts, and
that uses more intuition
from polynomials.
If we have one over a
second-order polynomial, we
can write it in a factored form
here, but we can expand
it in what we call partial
fractions.
We can expand this thing in
this sum, and if you think
about putting this over a common
denominator and working
out the relationship, this
difference, 4.5 over 1 minus
0.9R minus 3.5 over
1 minus 0.7R.
That's precisely the same using
the normal rules for
polynomials.
That's precisely the same
as that expression.
But the difference, from the
point of view of thinking
about systems, is enormous.
We know the answer
to that one.
That's the sum of the responses
to two first-order
systems, so we can write that
symbolically this way.
We can think about having
a sum system that
generates this term.
This term is a simple system of
the type of that we looked
at previously that, then,
gets multiplied by 4.5.
I'm just factoring again.
I'm saying I've got something
over something, which means
that I can put something in each
of two different parts of
two things that I multiply
together.
And I can think about this as
having been generated by this
system, and you just
add them together.
The amazing thing is that that
says that, despite the fact
that the response looked
complicated, it was in fact
the sum of two geometrics.
So it wasn't very different
from the answer
for a single pole.
What I've just done
is amazing.
I've just taken something that,
had you studied the
difference equations and had
you studied the block
diagrams, it would have been
very hard for you to conclude
that something this complicated
has a response
that can be written as the
sum of two geometrics.
By thinking about the system
as a polynomial in R, it's
completely trivial.
It's a simple application of the
rules for polynomials that
you all know.
So what we've shown, then, is
that this complicated system
has a way of thinking
about as just two
of the simpler systems.
The complicated response that
grew and decayed, that's just
the difference, really,
4.5 minus 3.5.
It's the weighted difference of
a part that goes 0.7 to the
n, then a different part
that goes 0.9 to the n.
So far, we've got to results,
the n equals 1 case, the
first-order polynomial in our
case, the one pole case,
that's trivial.
It's just a geometric
sequence.
The response is just a
geometric sequence.
If it happens to be
second-order, this is
second-order because when you
write the operator expression,
the polynomial in the bottom is
second-order, second-order
polynomial in R.
This second-order system
has a response that
looks like two pieces.
Each piece looks like a
piece that was from
a first-order system.
And in fact, that idea
generalizes.
If we have a system that can
be represented by linear
difference equation with
constant coefficients that
will always be true if the
system was constructed out of
the parts that we talked about,
adders, gains, delays.
If the system is constructed
out of adders, gains, and
delays, then it will be possible
to express the system
in terms of one difference
equation.
General form is showed here.
Y then can be constructed out
of parts that are delayed
versions of Y and delayed
versions of X. If you do that,
then you can always write the
operator that expresses the
ratio between the output and the
input as the ratio of two
polynomials.
That will always be true.
So this, now, is the
generalization step.
We did the n equals 1 case, we
did the n equals 2 case, and
now we're generalizing.
We will always get, for any
system that can be represented
by a linear difference equation
with constant
coefficients, we can always
represent the system
functional in this form.
Then just like we did in the
second-order case, we can use
the factor theorem to break
this polynomial in the
denominator into factors.
That comes from the factor
theorem in algebra.
Then we can re-express that in
terms of partial fractions.
And what I've just showed is
that, in the general case,
regardless of how many delays
are in the system, if the
system only has adders, gains,
and delays, I can always
express the answer as
a sum of geometrics.
That's interesting.
That means that if I knew the
bases for all of those
geometric sequences, I know
something about the response.
The bases are things
we call poles.
If you knew all the poles,
you'd know something very
powerful about the system.
So every one of the factors
corresponds to a pole, and by
partial fractions, you'll get
one response for each pole.
The response for each pole
goes like pole to the n.
You know the basic shape.
You don't know the constants,
but you know the basic shape
of the response just by
knowing the poles.
We can go one more step,
which makes the
computation somewhat simpler.
I used the factor theorem.
Here, I'm using the fundamental
theorem of
algebra, which says that if I
have a polynomial of order n,
I have n roots.
The poles are related to the
roots of the R polynomial.
The relationship is take
the functional,
substitute for R --
1 over Z. Re-express the
functional as a ratio of
polynomials in Z. The poles
are the roots of the
denominator.
So recapping, I started with
a first-order system.
I showed you how to get
a second-order system.
I showed that, in general, you
can use the factor theorem to
break down the response of a
higher-order system into a sum
of responses of first-order
systems.
Now, I've shown that you can use
the fundamental theorem of
algebra to find the poles
directly, and then by knowing
the poles, you know each of
the behaviors, monotonic
divergence, monotonic
convergence,
or alternating signs.
And so here is this same example
that I started with,
worked out by thinking about
what are the poles.
The poles are 0.7 and 0.9,
which we see by a simple
application of the fundamental
theorem of algebra.
OK, we got a long way by just
thinking about operators as
polynomials.
We haven't done anything
that you haven't
done in high school.
Polynomials are very familiar
and we've made an isomorphism
between systems and
polynomials.
OK, make sure you're
all with me.
Here's a higher order system.
How many of these statements
are true --
0, 1, 2, 3, 4, or 5?
Talk to your neighbor,
get an answer.
So how many are true --
0, 1, 2, 3, 4, or 5?
Oh, come on.
Blame it on your neighbor.
You weren't talking, but I
didn't hear you not talking.
How many are true --
0, 1, 2, 3, 4, or 5?
Raise your hands.
AUDIENCE: They can't
all be true.
PROFESSOR: They can't
Are they mutually
contradictory?
AUDIENCE: Well, yeah.
5 --
PROFESSOR: N1 of the above,
that sounds like--
OK, so you've eliminated 1.
Which one's true?
How many statements are true?
Looks like about 75%.
Correct?
What should I do?
How do I figure it out?
What's my first step?
What do I do?
AUDIENCE: Operators.
PROFESSOR: Operators,
absolutely.
So turn it into operators.
So take the difference
equation,
turn it into operators.
The important thing to see is
that there are three Y terms.
Take them all to the same side,
and I get an operator
expression like that.
The ones that depend on X, there
are two of them, that's
represented here.
The thing this is critical for
determining poles is figuring
out the denominator.
The poles are going to
come from this one.
After I get the ratio of two
polynomials in R, I substitute
1 over Z for each R. So for this
R, I get 1 over Z. For
this R squared, I get
1 over Z squared.
Then I want to turn it back into
a ratio of polynomials in
Z, so I have to multiply top
and bottom by Z squared.
And when I do that, I get this
ratio of polynomials in Z.
The poles are the roots of the
denominator polynomial in Z.
The poles are minus
1/2 and plus 1/4.
So the unit sample response
converges to 0.
What would be the condition
that that represents?
AUDIENCE: Take the polynomial
on the bottom.
PROFESSOR: Something about the
polynomial on the bottom.
Would all second-order systems
have that property that the
unit sample response would
converge to 0?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Louder?
AUDIENCE: Absolute value
of the poles?
PROFESSOR: Absolute value
of the poles has to be?
AUDIENCE: Less than 1.
PROFESSOR: Less than 1.
If the magnitude of the poles
is less than 1, then the
response magnitude will
decay with time.
So that's true here, and it
would be true so long as none
of the poles have a magnitude
exceeding 1.
There are poles at
1/2 and 1/4.
No, that's not right.
It's -1/2 or 1/4.
There's a pole at 1/2.
No, that's not right.
There's a pole at -1/2.
There are two poles.
Yes, that's true.
None of the above.
No, that's not true.
So the answer was (2).
Everybody's comfortable?
We've done something
very astonishing.
We took an arbitrary system, and
we've figured out a rule
that let's us break
it into the sum
of geometric sequences.
We can always write the response
to a unit sample
signal, we can always write, as
a weighted sum of geometric
sequences, and the number of
geometric sequences in the sum
is the number of poles, which
is the order of the operator
that operates on Y.
OK, so we've done
something very powerful.
There's one more thing that we
have to think about, and then
we have a complete picture
of what's going on.
Think about when you learned
polynomials.
One of the big shocks was that
roots can be complex.
What would that mean?
What would it mean if we had
a system whose poles were
complex valued?
So first off, does such
a system exist?
Well, here's one.
I just pulled that
out of the air.
If I think about the functional,
1 over (1 minus R
plus R squared) --
if I convert that into our ratio
of polynomials in Z and
then find the roots, I
find that the roots
have a complex part.
The roots are 1/2 plus or
minus root 3 over 2j.
There's an imaginary part.
So the question is what
would that mean?
Or is perhaps that system
just meaningless?
Well, complex numbers work in
algebra, and complex numbers
work here, too.
So the fact that a pole has a
complex value in the context
of signals and systems simply
means that the pole is
complex, that the base of the
geometric sequence, that base
is complex.
So that means that we can still
rewrite the denominator,
which was 1 minus R plus R
squared, we can rewrite that
denominator in terms of a
product of two first-order R
polynomials.
The coefficients are now
complex, but it still works.
The algebra still works right.
That has to work because that's
just polynomials.
That's the way polynomials
behave.
Now, we can still factor it.
We can still use the
factor theorem.
In fact, we can still use the
fundamental theorem of algebra
to find the poles
by the Z trick.
That's fine.
We can still use partial
fractions.
All of these numbers
are complex, but
the math still works.
The funny thing is that
it implies that
the fundamental modes--
by fundamental mode, I mean the
simple geometric for the
case of a first-order system,
more complex behaviors for
higher order systems.
The mode is the time response
associated with a pole.
So the modes are, in this case,
complexes sequences.
So in general, the modes
look like P0 to the n.
Here, my modes are simply
have a complex value.
So what did I say they were?
The poles were 1/2
plus or minus--
so my modes simply look that.
Same thing.
The strange thing that happened
was that those modes,
those geometric sequences, are
now have complex values.
The first one up here, if I just
look at the denominator,
these coefficients mean that
it's proportionate to the mode
associated with this, which is
that, which has a real part,
which is the blue part, and
the imaginary part,
which is a red part.
There were two poles,
plus and minus.
The other pole just flips
the imaginary part.
So if I have imaginary poles,
all I get is complex modes,
complex geometric sequences.
An easier way of thinking about
that is thinking about--
so when we had a simple, real
pole, we just had P0 to the n.
That's easy to visualize because
we just think about
each time you go from 0 to 1 to
2 to 3, it goes from 1 to
P0 to P0 squared to P0 cubed.
Here, when you're multiplying
complex numbers, it's easier
to imagine that on the
complex plane.
Think about the location of the
point 1, think about the
location of the point P0, think
about the location of
the point P0 squared, and in
this particular case, where
the pole was 1/2 plus or minus
the square root of 3 over 2
times j, this would
be pole to the 0.
This is pole to the 1.
This is pole squared,
pole cubed.
As you can see when you have a
complex number, the trajectory
in complex space can
be complicated.
In this case, it's circular.
The circular trajectory in the
complex plane corresponds to
the sinusoidal behavior
in time.
So there's a correlation between
the way you think
about the modes evolving on the
complex plane and the way
you think about the
real and imaginary
parts evolving in time.
It seems a little
weird that the
response should be complex.
We're studying this kind of
system theory primarily
because we're trying to gain
insight into real systems.
We want to know how things
like robots work.
How does the WallFinder work?
What would it mean if the
WallFinder went to position
one plus the square
root of 3 over 2j?
That doesn't make sense.
So there's a little bit of a
strange thing going on here.
How is it that we need complex
numbers to model real things?
That doesn't seem
to sound right.
But the answer is that, if the
difference equation had real
coefficients, as they will
for a real system--
if you think about a real
system, like a bank account,
the coefficients in the
difference equation are real
numbers, not complex numbers.
If you think about the
WallFinder system, the
coefficients in the WallFinder
system, the coefficients of
the difference equations--
the coefficients of the
different equations describe
the WallFinder behavior
were all real numbers.
Here, I'm thinking about the
denominator polynomial.
If we try to find the roots of a
polynomial, and if we find a
complex root, if the
coefficients were all real, it
follows that the complex
conjugate of the original root
is also a root.
That's pretty simple, if you
think about what it means to
be a polynomial.
If you think about a polynomial
is whatever--
so I've got 1 plus Z plus Z
squared plus blah, blah, blah.
2, 3 minus 16, if all of those
coefficients real, then the
only way the--
If P were a root of this
polynomial, then P* would have
to be a root, too, because if
you complex conjugate each of
the Z's, it's the same thing
as complex conjugating the
whole thing because the
coefficients are real valued.
So the idea then is that if I
happen to get a complex root
for my system that can be
described by real value
coefficients, it must also
be true that it's complex
conjugate is a root.
If that happens, the two roots
co-conspire so that the modes
have canceling imaginary
parts.
You can prove that.
I'm not worried about you being
able to prove that.
I just want you to understand
that if you have two roots
that are complex conjugates,
they can conspire to have
their imaginary parts
cancel, and that's
exactly what happens.
Here, in this example, the
example that I started with,
where the system was 1 over (1
minus R plus R squared), the
unit sample responses
showed here.
You can write as the sum of
sinusoidal and cosinusoidal
signals, and the sum that falls
out has the property
that the imaginary
parts cancel.
It's still useful to look at the
imaginary parts the same
as it is when you're trying
to solve polynomials.
It's useful because the
period of all of these
signals is the same.
If I think about the period of
the individual modes, if I
think about the period of P0
to the n, 1/2 plus or minus
root 3 over 2j to the n, the
period of that signal --
I can see in the complex plane,
this is the n equals 0,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, 10, 11, 12 --
the period is 6.
If I were to take the minus 1,
I would go around the circle
the other way.
This would be zero term 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, et cetera.
Both of the modes, the geometric
sequence associated
with the two complex conjugate
poles, both of those modes had
the same period, they're
both 6, as does the
response to the real part.
So you can deduce the period of
the real signal by looking
at the periods of the
two complex signals.
So think about this system.
Here, I've got a system whose
responses showed here.
I'm going to tell you that the
response was generated by a
second-order system, that
is to say a system whose
polynomial was second-order,
whose polynomial in R was
second-order.
Which of these statements
is true?
I want to think about the pole
as being a complex number.
Here, I'm showing you the
complex number in polar form.
It's got a magnitude and an
angle, and I'd like you to
figure how what must the
magnitude have been, and what
must the angle have been.
So what's the utility?
Why did I tell you the pole in
terms of it's magnitude and
angle rather than telling it to
you in it's Cartesian form
as a real and imaginary part?
What's good about thinking about
magnitude and angle?
Or if I break the pole into
magnitude and angle, and if I
think about the mode--
the modes are always of
the form P0 to the n.
If I think about modes as having
a magnitude and an
angle, when I raise it
to the n, something
very special happens.
What happens?
You can separate it.
What is R e to the j omega
raised to the n?
That's the same as R to the
n, e to the j n omega.
It's the product of a real
thing times a very simple
complex thing.
What's simple about
the complex thing?
The magnitude is everywhere
1 e to the j, the
magnitude of that term.
So all of the magnitude
is here, none of the
magnitude is here.
All of the angle is here, none
of the angle is here.
I've separated the magnitude
and the angle.
So it's very insightful to think
about poles in terms of
magnitude and angle because
it decouples the
parts of the mode.
So I can think, then, of this
complicated signal that I gave
you as being the product of a
magnitude part and a pure
angle part.
From the magnitude part, I can
infer something about R. R is
the ratio of the nth 1 to the
n minus 1-th one, so R is a
lot bigger than 1/2.
In fact, R in this
case is 0.97.
And this is pure angle.
This lets me infer something
about the oscillations.
In fact, I can say something
about the period.
The period is, here's a peak,
here's a peak, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12.
The period's 12.
If the period is 12,
what is omega?
Omega is a number, such that
by the time I got up to 12
times it, I got up to 2 pi.
What's omega?
AUDIENCE: Pi over 6.
PROFESSOR: 2 pi over 12.
So it's about 1/2.
So that's a way that I can infer
the form of the answer.
I ask you what pole corresponds
to this behavior.
Well, the decay that comes from
the real part, that comes
from R to the n.
The oscillation, that comes from
the imaginary part, and I
can figure that out by thinking
about the period and
thinking about that
relationship.
So the answer, then, is this
one, R is between 1/2 and 1,
and omega is about 1/2.
OK, one last-- whoops,
wrong button.
One last example.
So what we've seen is a very
powerful way of decomposing
systems, so that we can always
think about them in terms of
poles and complex geometrics,
which we will call modes,
poles and modes.
And that behavior works for
any system in an enormous
class of systems, so I want to
think about one last one,
which is Fibonacci sequence.
You all know the Fibonacci
sequence.
You've all programmed it.
We started with that when we
were doing Python, and we made
some illustrations about the
recursion and all that sort of
thing by thinking about it.
Now, I'm going to
use signals and
systems do the same problem.
So Fibonacci was interested
in population growth.
How many pairs of rabbits can be
produced from a single pair
in a year if it is suppose that
every month each pair
begets a new pair, from which
the second month it becomes
productive?
OK, it's not quite the same
English I would have used.
From this statement, you can
infer a difference equation.
I've written it in terms of
X. What do you think X is?
X is the input signal, and here,
I'm thinking about X as
something that's specifies
the initial condition.
This is the thing I alluded
to earlier.
One trick that we use to make it
easy to think about initial
conditions is that we embed
them in the input.
So in this particular case, I'll
think about the initial
condition arising from
a delta function.
If I think about X as a delta,
then the sequence of results
Y0, Y1, Y2, Y3 from this
difference equation, is the
conventional Fibonacci
sequence.
It would correspond to what if
you had a baby rabbit, one
baby rabbit, that's the
one, in generation
0, that's the delta.
So the input is a way that
I can specify initial
conditions, and that's a very
powerful way of thinking about
initial conditions.
So here's the problem.
I've got one set of baby
rabbits at times 0.
They grow up.
They have baby rabbits, which
grow up at the same time the
parents had more baby rabbits,
at which point more babies
grow into bigger rabbits.
And big rabbits have more
babies, et cetera, et cetera,
et cetera, et cetera,
et cetera.
So you all know that.
You all know about Fibonacci
sequence.
It blows up very quickly.
What are the poles of the
Fibonacci sequence?
The difference equation looks
just like the difference
equations we've looked
at throughout
this hour and a half.
We can do it just like we did
all the other problems.
We write the difference equation
in terms of R. We
rewrite the system functional
in terms of a ratio of two
polynomials in R. We substitute
R goes to 1 over Z,
deduce a ratio of polynomials in
Z, factor the denominator,
find the roots of the
denominator, and find that
there are two poles.
The poles for the Fibonacci
sequence are plus or minus the
root of 5 over 2.
That's curious.
There's no recursion there.
It's a different way of
thinking about things.
There are two poles.
The first pole, the
plus one --
1 plus the root of 5 over 1,
corresponds to a pole whose
magnitude is bigger than 1.
It explodes.
There it is.
The second one is a
negative number.
So the first one is the
golden ratio, 1.618...
The second one is the negative
reciprocal of the golden
ratio, which is -0.618...
And those two numbers,
amazingly, conspire so that
their sum, horrendous as they
are, is an integer.
And in fact, that's the integer
that we computed here.
So we've used Fibonacci before
to think about the way you
structure programs, iteration,
recursion, that sort of thing.
Here, by thinking about signals
and systems, we can
think about exactly the
same problem as poles.
There's no complexity
in this problem.
It doesn't take N or N
squared or N log N
or anything to compute.
It's closed form.
The answer is (pole one) to the
N plus (pole two) to the
N. That's it.
That's the answer.
So what we've done is we found
a whole new way of thinking
about the Fibonacci sequence
in terms of poles, and more
than that, we found that that
way of thinking about poles
works for any difference
equation of this type.
And we found that poles, this
way of thinking about systems
in terms of polynomials, is a
powerful abstraction that's
exactly the same kind
of PCAP abstraction
that we used for Python.